I am captain america
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
falcon and winter soldier episode 5 video there
were so many easter eggs and obviously some big
setups and a genuine post-credits scene they're
doing the one division thing where the last
couple of episodes each have a post-credits
scene if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
also be doing episode videos for loki which is
going to start after the falcon and winter soldier
finale in june so i'll remind everybody about that
in the next couple of weeks careful for spoilers
if you have not seen the episode yet because there
were some really big reveals so we'll just start
at the beginning of the episode and i'll number
these as we go along talking about big wtf moments
and easter eggs as we go along starting with
the title of the episode which was truth so some
of you may have read the isaiah bradley origin
story comic book it's called captain america red
white and black truth and it basically tells the
story that isaiah bradley told to falcon during
the episode it's pretty accurate to the comics but
they kind of do the cliff notes version like i was
a little disappointed they didn't do full-blown
flashbacks with this character but it was a great
scene nonetheless they've only changed a couple
minor things about the isaiah bradley character
from the comics so i'll explain that when we get
to that part of the episode but the actual episode
starts with john walker directly after the events
of him killing that black smasher with all the
camera phones people recording him and it seems
like he just bolted out of the square to get away
from all those phones he has all these flashbacks
to lamar from before the mission telling him not
to go into the building yet cursing himself for
not listening blaming lamar's death a little bit
on himself he rests his head on the shield and
it seems like he's recognized what he does for a
second like for a moment he's just sort of filled
with all this regret and this pain and grief over
lamar's death there's this really sad soundtrack
playing over all these scenes like you really do
feel for him for a second but then sort of a funny
turn like on a dime he just turns like well back
to duty like he just wipes it all away nope that's
in the past fully compartmentalized there are also
repeated shots of the blood on the shield which
is still dripping down just to show you how fresh
this all is then when falcon and winter soldier
come running in you could just sense for a moment
like he's just completely past it like okay guys
let's plan what we're going to do next we need to
go after carly and falcon has to stop him dead in
his tracks like no dude you need to chill and give
us the shield back nobody else needs to get hurt
remember falcon was a grief counselor he has this
really nice talk with winter soldier towards the
end of the episode telling him about the right way
that he needs to be making amends using that list
of his that we saw earlier in the series obviously
that was all set up for yori's arc and him finding
out about his dead son that winter soldier killed
so i'll talk about that in a second too but
obviously we knew where this was all headed is
all just building up to them double teaming john
walker when he just completely goes over the edge
is as if you're watching a giant car crash play
out in slow motion as john walker kind of realizes
what's happening oh oh so that's how it is he
goes from zero to full hulk out mode on a dime
is almost funny if it weren't so tragic what was
happening here when winter soldier tries to tell
him that he knows from experience it doesn't end
well going down the dark side that way he's trying
to tell him about his time as winter soldier as
an assassin like that will not end well for you
of course john walker denies it all i'm nothing
like you but they keep showing you the bloody
shield is still dripping blood bucky's able to get
the shield from him for a hot second just another
subtle reference to bucky being captain america
in the comics first stretch after steve rogers
was there been a bunch of times in the series
where both winter soldier and falcon have used the
shield obviously it's all about falcon becoming
the next captain america and him fully wielding
the shield but they're just playing with that idea
like bucky has used the shield in the comics a lot
too the fight does remind me a little bit of
the fight from captain america civil war where
bucky and captain america are tag teaming iron
man i guess you could think of falcon as being
the person in the iron man suit but obviously
the dynamics are very different the context is
very different for this fight than the captain
america civil war fight because john walker has
taken the super soldier's serum all of his blows
land way harder i think they're able to have a
little bit more fun with the fight choreography
too because you have two super soldiers because
obviously bucky is a super soldier as well he is
able to disable winter soldier's arm just a little
bit i think that's also kind of foreshadowing for
whatever eventual battle they'll have during the
finale because obviously this isn't going to be
the last time they'll fight john walker they just
want to make it seem like bucky isn't invincible
against john walker like the wakandans of course
you would expect them to know how to disable a
vibranium weapon that they themselves created
but they want to make it seem like john walker
is just as capable of a fighter and now that
he's as strong as bucky he can match him blow for
blow then he almost straight up kills falcon the
same way that he killed that black smasher until
bucky's able to stop him he's yelling like a crazy
man i am captain america while he rips falcon's
wings off obviously that's all foreshadowing for
the big payoff with his new wakandan vibranium
suit i'll talk about that in a second too
and everyone's kind of disappointed they didn't
show you what's in the briefcase what's in the
box show me what's in the box yes we all
know exactly what's in that box but it's
almost hilarious how crazy john walker has gone
he's full-blown crazy town i would say he even
sounds crazier than wanda did during Wandavision
and she went full blown crazy then the two of them
literally have to pry it right off of his arm
they're only able to get it off by breaking his
arm he's screaming the whole time in rage like how
dare you try to do this to me i am captain america
bucky then drops the shield down next to falcon
gives him that knowing look like here dude here's
the shield it's your responsibility take the damn
shield anthony mackie was great during the episode
but i really loved his reaction in this moment too
like he touches the blood on the shield like he's
just horrified like how could it have come to
this later after things chill out just a little
bit falcon claims that carly's bolted we don't
find out till later that she's actually gone
to new york city like she's literally sitting in
new york city getting ready for their big attack
don't worry we'll talk about the big sharon carter
twist with batroc the leaper in a second because
that was a big twist they said at the plotline
with the grc rounding up all the refugees that
they talk about at the end of the episode they're
basically going to deport them in mass that's what
this big vote is all about then as bucky takes
off to find zemo torres shows up you also notice
that falcon has cleaned the blood off of captain
america's shield he says that the story line with
the u.s military basically taking john walker to
test stripping him of the captain america name but
they also said it the whole idea of falcon's new
suit like he tells him what happened here and he
doesn't reveal what john walker did which i think
might wind up biting him in the ass later like it
sounds like falcon didn't fully report john walker
completely going off the rails the way he did
almost killing him in that fight the way they
explained it later in the episode during his trial
the only reason why they're stripping john walker
the captain america name is just because of the
bad pr that he created by killing that flag
smasher in public or at least by getting caught
doing it in public but the whole idea with having
john walker destroy his last falcon suit is to
give him a logical reason to need another one
a replacement that probably just happens to
look like the captain america version of the
falcon suit that he got when he became captain
america in the comics also when he tells torres
to keep the wings like he doesn't want them back
it's also a reference to torres being the next
version of falcon taking up that name when falcon
became captain america in the comics then we go
back to washington dc and it's actually the same
military official or the same government official
who falcon gave the shield back to in episode one
and who unveiled john walker's the next captain
america who basically strips him of the title
and all of his military rank and benefits they
basically take the military away from him like
his entire life has been all about the military
doing what he's told being this good soldier and
they basically just kind of yank that back because
as julia louie dreyfus explains i'll explain her
character in a second because it got caught
killing the flag smasher in public otherwise
they probably would have given him a medal had he
killed all of them like they wouldn't have cared
at all like oh this is so wonderful thank you
for cleaning up this problem it's just that he
got caught doing it in public and it became this
big international pr incident but the whole idea
is they're basically telling him the only reason
we're not throwing you in jail for what you did is
because you were so decorated as a hero before and
you know later they kind of pay that off when he's
forging his new captain america shield he takes
his highest honor his medal of honor and embeds it
in the new version of the shield that he's making
this is basically him going from being captain
america to being u.s agent like the super patriot
character in the comics they've been foreshadowing
this turn through the entire series but i think
we all expected him to be a version of u.s
agent from the comics who was just a very very
dark character compared to steve rogers and was
actually kind of a captain america villain for
a little while too but then we get our big mega
cameo scene is julie louis dreyfus who introduces
herself as contessa valentina allegra de fontaine
who is madame hydra from the comics but originally
she was a russian sleeper agent who joined shield
and nick fury early on in her career but she
was this russian sleeper agent the whole time
she went on to become one of the leaders within
shields structure then wound up infiltrating hydra
later as part of a secret plot to betray them
betray hydra to leviathan she does come from the
classic captain america stories in strange tales
but she doesn't have any special powers she's just
like a black widow style character a little bit
like baron zemo's character as well just very good
at manipulating other people very good at spy
trade i also kind of think now that she is the
power broker character even though there's even
more strong evidence for sharon carter possibly
being the power broker i'll talk about that in a
second too because sharon carter does kind of seem
like she's gone dark and she's playing both sides
but julia louis dreyfus's character is the only
one who genuinely feels like a villain character
hiding in broad daylight she mysteriously knows
everything about him taking the super soldier
serum what happened with the flag smashers as
if she's been watching this all play out the
entire time since the beginning of the series
when she says don't worry i know you took the
serum it's one of the best decisions you ever made
it's made you very attractive to some people what
she means by some people is she's talking about
the power broker probably because she is the power
broker herself or at least there's strong evidence
that she could be the power broker it just feels
like they wouldn't cast such a big notable actor
in a role like this unless there was going to be
an even bigger twist in the finale i think this is
all going to wind up dovetailing with sharon
carter's storyline but they're not going to
resolve a lot of that till the finale like there
will be some connection between sharon carter's
character and julia louis-dreyfus character the
contessa then she says the best decision he's
going to make is just answer the phone when she
calls him there's a bunch of trailer footage from
next week's episode i'll talk about that when i
do another trailer video for the finale but it
seems like she's going to be the one to activate
him against the flag smashers she also makes that
clever reference about captain america shield
technically not belonging to the us government
it's a bit of a gray area what she means is is
that they probably acquired it through really
shady means back during world war ii or howard
stark acquired it for the government through very
shady means kind of implying that it was stolen
from wakanda so technically the shield belongs
to the wakandans not to the us government but i
believe within the mcu the way they're explaining
her character is that she's just a powerful figure
inside the government probably connections to the
military the weapons plus program because of the
super soldier serum because she seems to know so
much about it dr nagel and the power broker
probably on the slide because she might wind
up being the power broker herself i also love the
funny reaction to the business card like what is
this there's nothing on here it's just a regular
card then as we all expected winter soldier finds
nemo at the sokovian memorial thinking about his
family he claims he's not going to try and kill
winter soldier anymore like there's no bad blood
between them but the way their talk goes down
when he says they're going to do things their way
falcon and winter soldier i think zemo expected
winter soldier to kill him like okay well fine
then this is the way it was supposed to end anyway
like he's prepared to die but when he reveals
that he took the bullets out of the gun it's
just meant to show you that he's beaten his
programming like he's trying to tell zemo
i am not the winner soldier anymore we find out
that he's actually called in the wakandans and is
handing him over then the wakandans io tell
us that they're taking him to the raft this
will obviously make a lot of you comic book fans
really excited because you know thunderbolt ross
controls the rap that's like his home base now
obviously this is all kinds of foreshadowing for
thunderbolts hopefully there'll be some sort of
post credit scene in the finale to really set this
up but the whole idea is that thunderbolt ross
keeps all the biggest super villains in the mcu
inside the raft where no other prison would be
able to hold them normally so hopefully when
we eventually see a thunderbolts disney plus
series that will be where their home base is
because thunderbolt ross wouldn't want the rest
of the world finding out of their team's existence
and because between missions they just have to
go back to their cells the whole idea of the
thunderbolts is they just get some of the time cut
off of their sentence in most of the thunderbolts
characters have done such terrible things that
they're serving multiple life sentences so even
if they completed a couple missions they'd still
be sitting in prison for a long long time they
told us a long time ago that falcon and winter
soldier series was helping set up thunderbolts
so obviously this big twist isn't a huge surprise
it was just a question of how they were going to
foreshadow thunderbolts really expecting them to
put john walker on the team because he is a super
soldier so he does have some superpowers and he's
definitely on the outs with the us military now
then when bucky asks io for the favor that's
obviously the big setup for falcon to get a new
vibranium falcon suit that looks like his captain
america comic book suit i also kind of love io's
interaction with bucky here too she tells him
that he'd be better off making himself scarce in
wakanda until all this blows over meaning don't go
showing your face around in public back in wakanda
anytime soon because they're all still a little
bit salty that he helped zemo break out a prison
black panther not super happy about that that
dude killed my father how dare you break him out
of prison but she's also telling him in so many
words that he does still have a home in wakanda
he's still welcome there eventually after this
kind of blows over which might be a teaser for
potential winter soldier cameo in black panther
too i'm also kind of hoping that bucky winds up
showing up on the black panther disney plus series
that they announced that they're doing next year
i don't know exactly when they're going to
start filming or which characters they're
going to use but there will be a black
panther spin-off series on disney plus
then falcon goes back to isaiah bradley's to
get the full backstory on what happened to him
back in the 1950s around the korean war with his
super soldier serum and like i said it's basically
them doing that captain america red white and
black truth comic book story isaiah bradley
references the red tails 332 that's the tuskegee
airman a group of black pilots from world war ii
that's actually real world history that he's
talking about george lucas even made a movie
about them called red tails starring former roadie
terence howard from the first iron man movie
falcon wants to know why isaiah bradley didn't
just become the next version of captain america
because he was a super soldier and he's more
optimistic about it but isaiah bradley basically
explains that they would not accept him would
not allow him to be captain america back then
then he explains the full story of the super
soldier program at that time the weapons plus
program he says they tested a bunch of different
versions of the super soldier serum on a squad of
black soldiers that he was part of then they would
send them out on missions just to see what would
happen to see if the serums would work some of the
participants wound up dying some had severe side
effects some of them went crazy like he says most
of the other versions of the serum were unstable
but for some reason it worked in him and they
never quite found out why then during one of
their missions a bunch of the test subjects got
captured the military commanders of the time just
wanted to bomb the whole pow camp to destroy
all evidence that the super soldier program
existed what they were doing to them isaiah
bradley pulled a steve rogers captain america
went rogue to go save all their lives brought them
back but turns out they wound up dying from the
side effects of the serum later anyway that's when
they locked up isaiah bradley and just continued
to test him to try and find out why the serum
worked on him the scars that he was showing falcon
even that looked really horrific that's basically
all the marks from the test that they performed on
him but a lot of you probably sensed the easter
egg here so obviously him saving his squad mates
is meant to be a very dark parallel for steve
rogers in the first captain america movie breaking
away from his regular duties going rogue to save
all the soldiers in the pow camp during world war
ii including the howling commandos when he
brought them back he was celebrated as a hero
but when isaiah bradley did the same thing during
the korean war they locked him up as a criminal
but about 30 years later in the 1980s there was
a nurse at the facility where he was being tested
and held who took pity on him who basically
helped him fake his death using paperwork
gave him all of his wife's letters and then
basically helped him escape when falcon tries
to get him to go public like you could tell people
about your story he doesn't believe me he's like
no they would kill me on the spot to prevent my
story from getting out when falcon says he knows
people that could help he's talking about the
other avengers characters who are still alive
early theory when falcon becomes the next captain
america eventually he'll get justice for isaiah
bradley and they'll give isaiah bradley a special
section inside this exhibit next to all the steve
rogers captain america stuff you notice when
falcon goes to call his sister too to tell
her that he's coming home with captain america's
shield you see the wallpaper on his phone there
it's a little kid with his dad that's probably
falcon as a child with his father because he
references his father a lot when they talk about
the family boat there's a whole story line with
them fixing the boat up they actually use the boat
as a metaphor for captain america's shield in the
captain america name because it's all about his
sister eventually coming around and not wanting
to get rid of the boat like no we need to keep
this as part of our legacy it's an important part
of our history we can't get rid of it's basically
the same arc for falcon during the episode falcon
says the captain america name the shield is very
complicated the history is very complicated but he
doesn't want to run from that anymore they have
some really solid montages i love it when bucky
shows up and they have some of that buddy cop
energy he shows up as if he's a delivery boy like
i'm just here to deliver this special vibranium
suit that the wakandans gave me just sign for it
and i'll be on my way you find out that bucky is
actually a pretty decent mechanic probably learned
it during world war ii we also see john walker
meet with battlestar with lamar's family during
this period he also kind of lies about the flag
smasher attack yes i killed the man who killed
your son technically that isn't true carly is
the person who killed lamar and i think the whole
idea with him walking past that captain america
poster like cap is back seeing it after he's been
stripped of the title is just further cementing
the idea that he believes he is captain america
i am captain america and that's why he forges
himself another shield but then we get that really
crazy sharon carter scene back in madrapore i'm
not exactly sure what this painting is but it's
just meant to be commentary on the actual plot
of the episode she reveals that she got batroc
the leaper out of prison in algeria where falcon
took him down during episode 1 and reveals that
she was the person who hired him for that job
that he was on to capture that military personnel
when falcon took him down in the first place
it's not really clear why she wanted that person
captured it probably has something to do with
her illicit business that she's been conducting
they raised more questions than they answered
during this episode but at the end of the episode
we find out that she's actually hired the truck to
actually arm the flag smashers for their attack on
the grc now even though it makes her seem kind
of like a villain i think she's actually just
playing four-dimensional chess and she just wants
to get at the grc like it's all part of her agenda
that's separate from what's happening with falcon
and winter soldier and when batroc said that he's
there to kill the falcon it's not that sharon
carter wants the falcon dead she probably just
told him that that he could get his revenge as a
way to get him to do what she wanted like she's
manipulating batroc herself i think it's all just
meant to be a big misdirect and she's working some
long con but then back at falcons the next morning
bucky wakes up on the couch seeing his nephews
falcon's nephews playing with captain america
shield obviously just foreshadowing falcon
training with it later and becoming the next
captain america then even though this is all
about falcon training with the shield this big
moment of bucky sort of working through a lot of
his ptsd and explaining himself to falcon like why
this means so much to him why he's making such a
big deal about the shield saying that it basically
represents his family it's like the last thing he
has left that in captain america's book of bliss
the thing that makes him feel like a real person
grounded in reality and not some cyborg killing
machine like when he was a winter soldier
then because falcon's whole thing is that he was
a grief counselor for the military for veterans
he gives bucky this big talk about what he needs
to do to find closure himself helping other people
that he wronged find closure he says i bet
there's one person in your book that only you
can help find closure and obviously that's a big
reference to yuri helping him find closure over
what happened to his son revealing that he himself
winter soldier killed him in the past falcon also
says that captain america is gone he says steve
is gone but that doesn't mean that he's dead if
you remember way back in episode 1 when they're
walking through the captain america exhibit if you
zoom in enhance on some of these parts i believe
it says that steve rogers officially retired after
the events of avengers endgame which i believe
dovetails with all the talk about him secretly
being in space like retiring to space possibly
nick fury's space station from spider-man far from
home we'll see if they pay that off by the finale
hopefully there'll be some sort of tag scene
that'll explain or clarify what's happened with
old man steve rogers [ __ ] also makes another
avengers end game reference saying that bucky
crossing the names off his list making amends
was him avenging the people that he killed when he
was winter soldier but carly winds up activating
all the flag smasher sleepers in the area just to
show how much support for their causes those are
all the people that you see in the trailer footage
wearing the masks infiltrating that grc facility
as it starts at the beginning of the episode then
they sort of explain what's going on in new york
city with this vote the grc is enacting the patch
act it's all about deporting the refugees and they
just want to make it seem like the other members
of the council at least are trying to care for the
welfare of these people and this one government
official the person who is behind all the captain
america government stuff doesn't care about them
at all and just wants to blow past this like do
we even need to vote on this we have troops in
place we can get rid of them right now in right
on cue the flag smashers enact their attack
obviously that'll play out during the finale
but we jump back to falcon at his home opening the
vibranium suit but they pull a pulp fiction and
hold the reveal to the finale pretty predictable
like you see a little bit of white there obviously
like i said it's probably a version of his captain
america suit from the comics then we get the big
post credit scene with john walker forging himself
a new captain america shield going full u.s agent
now he doesn't have extra vibranium so that is
just a regular metal shield but everybody let me
know in the comments post all your theories about
julia louis dreyfus contessa character do you
think that she's really the power broker and all
the sharon carter stuff is just big misdirection
and what kind of thunderbolts teasers do you think
we'll see in the finale post all your predictions
for the way you think they're going to end the
series what kind of post credit scenes you think
we'll see i'll do a trailer video for the finale
next but my full falcon winter soldier episode 6
video will post next friday just like normal
then i'll start doing some more loki bonus
videos there'll be more loki footage and trailers
in the next couple of weeks too everyone click
here for all my falcon and winter soldier episode
videos and click here for that brand new marvel
loki trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!